- [Kelly] Um, this is what's
most important people.
You just went to Vegas-
- Yeah.
- and you saw magic Mike live.
So what is your view? Should I go?
- I'm really glad we were getting
to the really important stuff immediately.
- I wanted, I like to get
to the hard hitting press,
which is the news that people wanna hear.
- Listen, we have kids.
(Kelly laughing)
We were, I was with my
children whom I love,
I have a one-year-old and
a, almost four year old.
I was with them staring
at them for 18 months.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you need a minute.
- And so when magic Mike opened,
it was literally the opening day.
I went with my girlfriends. (laughs)
- [Kelly] Why not?
- It was like, it was, they had just
opened it back up in Vegas.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You know, you had to
show your vaccinations,
but you could kind of
tell people were like,
is this gonna work? Is
this like safe to have it?
And I was like, I don't care.
(audience laughing)
- I don't think anyone cared.
Like, let me go to a show.
- And it was, it was amazing.
It was amazing. It was like
the movie, but a Vegas show.
A lot of great looking guys.
Have so many eight packs.
like I-
- Like I. Yeah, I totally
have packs as well.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, so it's a great mom's
night out though. Like it's fun.
- We did uh, one night in
Vegas with all my, you know,
my friends, like my daughter's,
has her little friends at
school and it was their moms.
We went, the six of us, but I will say
that we went to the 10:00 show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
And, um...
The show, my only
complaint about the show,
which is so good, was that
it's like two and a half hours long.
So 45 minutes in, I was
like, I've seen it all. I'm-
(audience laughing)
I gotta go to bed.
- Yeah.
- I'm a mom. I normally go
to sleep at 9:30 at night-
- Oh my God, I love that you say that.
- 'cause, as soon as I put my kids down,
I'm like, when they sleep, I sleep.
- Yeah.
- I've got, yeah, I'm tired.
- So it's like 12:45 at
night and everyone was like,
"I guess we should keep raging."
And so we stayed out until 2:00 AM,
but I was like, my heart
wanted to go to sleep at 9:45.
- Okay, so I've done that,
and the hard part of that
is that you've still, you're
not 24 anymore, right.
And so you feel that.
You feel the 2:00 AM for
like three days? I feel it.
- Yes. Exactly.
- I'm like, what did I do?
- [Mindy] No. So I, my
only note to magic Mike
is that it could be
slightly more succinct.
- [Kelly] Okay. I like it.
Just give me a little synopsis.
- [Mindy] Just a little synopsis.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Mindy] A couple, some abs-
- Yeah
- Some sexy men, and then go home.